okay they're about to lock me in here
and then use these electric coils to
make magnetic fields that rotate they're
roughly the strength of Earth's magnetic
field and we'll see if my brain is
picking up on the fact that the magnetic
field is changing the whole time I'll
have my eyes closed
it'll be pitch black in here basically
no stimuli except for the changing
magnetic field and I'll keep my head
perfectly still facing forward that
sound good yeah gonna take about eight
minutes eight minutes perfect okay I'm
ready when you are but before we do this
let's meet the researchers can you
introduce yourself interest master ah my
name is chin chin mojo I'm a professor
in neuroscience and experiment
psychology up here
Caltech Bharati Connie you are the first
author here and your paper has just been
published when this video goes out so
what is the setup of the paper how do
you set this up so basically we wanted
to see if humans have any brain response
to a magnetic field
it has long been recognized that certain
bird species have a remarkable ability
to find their way home hence the use of
homing pigeons to carry messages for us
their impeccable sense of direction is
owed in part to their ability to sense
the Earth's magnetic field but they are
not the only animals that do this
certain bacteria bees salmon turtles
rats dog wear cats in all of them are
known to have magnetic compass dogs
known to poop with their bodies oriented
preferentially north-south have even
been trained to locate bar magnets given
a choice between three containers they
were much better than chance at
identifying the one containing the
magnet in fact they were much better at
finding a magnet than finding a food
treat under similar conditions given all
these examples it seems more likely that
humans should have the ability to detect
magnetic fields and if you're wondering
how humans could physically pick up the
magnetic fields consider that magnetite
crystals have been found in the brain
that closely resembled those of
magnetically active bacteria my cooties
in neuroscience said wow this is hard to
believe you know this is impossible
but lots of biologists and geophysicist
said well it's a matter of course humans
are not you no exception among all those
mammalian species but up till now the
evidence has been contradictory and
controversial so in the early 80s
Robin Baker did some studies where they
took groups of students and drove them
around in very convoluted routes around
the English countryside and they were
blindfolded and then they would stop the
bus and ask the students to identify
which direction they came from so it's
basically home and they got a pretty
significant results from that shortly
afterwards maybe a few years afterwards
this study was attempted again at
Princeton University and they did just a
very similar experiment there and they
couldn't get significant behavioral
there that's a controversy lots of
positive reports and the failure of the
application negative data in your sense
as well so let's step back and then see
if there's any systematic selective
response from the brain to the magnetic
field itself not anything associated
like vestibular thing or visual scene
so this is um is that the way we get in
yes that's the way you're through
crouching so I'm gonna I'm gonna crawl
under there hang in a sec hang on this
is too cool I really like it what whose
chair is that Joe's declining the chair
and not used for this purpose but it
turned out it's very relaxing and the
main reason of this cage is to shear the
outside effect for one thing and also
have a good control over the modified
Faraday cage where F twisty is running
okay as I'm there's no sound or vision
or tactile or any other additional
stimulation because we are tapping onto
very subtle response of the brain of the
subliminal subconscious level it doesn't
block the Earth's magnetic field there's
a magnetic field goes straight through
this and that's actually sort of what we
want because inside the chamber we're
not trying to override the Earth's field
we're just trying to redirect it just to
add a little bit of field here and here
remove a little bit there and by doing
that we can smoothly move the field back
and forth and move it in a way that
relates to how someone might experience
the field us they're sort of moving you
know around outside so that's
essentially what you're simulating in
here yes is you're making it as though
my head is swimming around in the
Earth's magnetic field yes except that
if you actually doing it in the real
world then your vestibular system is
also sending signals we are not
interested in contamination
basura signals so we would like to
generate artificially that kind of
situation like this however eliminating
any other accessory modalities such as
this do now can I hop in there and just
have a look okay I mean I feel like for
my job I have been in more weird
sand proof boxes than most people
these black coils here do these create
the magnetic field different experiment
so the magnet coils are actually these
things those are the magnetic coils and
you can see there's four of these square
coils yeah in all three directions and
this is a nested three axis coil set and
it's designed to create a magnetic field
in any direction inside the the chamber
and in the center of the chamber where
your head and torso is going to be
mm-hmm it's designed to create a uniform
field so a field with no gradients or
curves in it I've brought a compass and
so I can just see if the magnetic field
is changing what's gonna happen when I
sit in this room okay that was a pretty
traumatic shift so there will be two
kinds of rotations one is clockwise and
one is counterclockwise and as a control
on some trials the magnetic field won't
change at all so we can compare on
trials what happens after the field
rotation versus trials where no field
rotated so this is the sort of thing
that I'll be experiencing but in the
dark yep now we're gonna want you to use
your left hand to hold it here it's
easier than the front the cap yet
on this cap there are 64 electrodes
which will pick up the electrical
activity of my brain and you're sure
this isn't just to make people look
stupid when you're awake with your eyes
closed the dominant signal is called the
alpha wave and most people it occurs
around 10 Hertz these little squiggles
right here they're having at around 10
times per second these are the alpha and
alpha wave which is known to be an
indicator of relaxing and sometimes even
drowsy but not sleeping and then when
you notice something like in vision or
audition or touch your alpha wave is
suppressed and that is the signature of
a brain detecting sensory signal and
moving attention to other so the goal of
this experiment is to determine if a
magnetic field rotation causes the
amplitude of alpha waves to drop about
to go into the cage
I can't turn off the light and then we
just do this with a stool turn off all
the lights in the room and we close the
doors and throw the experiment I'll be
listening in and watching the video
first
here your name yes it can I'm setting up
the experiment will be sir teacher
latest wait for their thinking bits
Garmin is starting you can see that's
our starting point
direction it will
very from
to preset value
[Music]
okay this is like one of the more
glamorous I was thinking about saying
some of the camera I can't wait to see
the results though this is a section of
my raw EEG results you can see that
every three seconds the field was
rotated either clockwise counter
clockwise or it was fixed meaning it
didn't change now it's impossible to
draw conclusions just by looking at this
so the scientists average over all the
trials in the different conditions and
plot the alpha power over all the
electrodes this is a recording from
someone who is particularly sensitive to
changes in the magnetic field as I play
this watch how the clockwise and
counterclockwise responses compared to
the fixed field result the recording
starts before a rotation the magnetic
stimulus takes place and now observe the
post stimulus response particularly for
counterclockwise for this subject the
counter clockwise rotation resulted in a
clear decrease in alpha power of at
least three decibels shown by the dark
blue color this corresponds to a
decrease in alpha power by around 50%
now here are my results after the
magnetic stimulus my response to
counterclockwise is clearly not as
pronounced but over time for clockwise
rotations my alpha power is reduced I
was told I was neither the most
sensitive to magnetic fields nor the
least sensitive I was somewhere in the
middle so the conclusion is that our
brains have ability to sense molecule
change but it's implicit on subliminal
it's non conscious part of the brain
this is just the first step to make sure
that it's not theoretically impossible
that our ancestors might have utilized
this ability for the navigation even the
modem people like ourselves may
potentially however this will open up
the window for the next
stage research as to how we could bring
it to the consciousness how could we
strengthen them and how could we utilize
it as yet it's unclear if anyone can
actually make use of this sense
consciously or subconsciously to help
them navigate but the study's authors
point out that a surprising number of
human languages lack terms like front
back left and right and instead use
cardinal directions north south east and
west native speakers of such languages
would refer to a nearby tree as being to
their north rather than being in front
of them individuals who've been raised
from an early age within a linguistic
social and spatial framework using
cardinal reference cues might have made
associative links with geomagnetic
sensory cues to aid in daily life in
other words people from such cultures
may be conscious of their
magnetoreception they would be very
interesting to test but if it turns out
that this sense is no longer functional
in humans just a relic from our
ancestors it would be interesting to
consider why we lost it maybe more than
while that human don't need it that's
one explanation another explanation is
we are surrounded so much and exposed so
much to an artificially created strong
Lamonica feels starting from the
airplane cabinet head form some younger
people are wearing this for $10 per day
including MRI scanner to him so it's
possible our internal compass may be a
victim of our modern technology this
study does not show that magnetic fields
have some kind of special influence on
you that they don't cure disease they
don't make you smarter you can't
communicate telepathically or something
through them so these are the types of
emails that Connie does not want to
receive just so it just so everyone's
clear in case you've got sort of a crazy
idea my hair still looks stupid in case
you have a crazy idea for what to do
with magnetic fields and the human brain
this this study does not support that no
it does not support that no Leary
supports that the human brain
and pick up on the physical stimulus of
the Earth's magnetic field yep
weaken itself is a super cool finding it
is a super cool finding it such as the
basis for for future research because
you know you can't have any behavior
without some kind of something going on
in your brain
[Music]